and book TVs live coverage of the
Savannah Book Festival now continues
here's author and former CIA agent
William Doherty talking about in the
shadow of the Ayatollah
good afternoon we have a few more people
coming in but we're going to go ahead
and get started how are you enjoying the
Book Festival so far my name is Diane
Thompson and we're delighted to have you
join us and the 10th annual anniversary
of the Savannah Book Festival presented
by Georgia Power and the Shannon Family
Foundation we are blessed to have such
celebrated authors in Trinity United
Methodist Church today which has been
made possible by the generosity of Kurt
and liebe Anderson we'd also like to
extend special thanks to our literati
members and individual donors who have
made and continue to make Saturday's
free festival events possible before we
get started I have a couple of
housekeeping notes immediately following
this presentation
William Doherty will be signing festival
purchased copies of his book until fair
square he does have an interview with
c-span directly after this so he may be
just a few minutes late getting there we
have a new policy this year if you're
planning to stay for the next author
presentation please move forward in the
menu so the ushers can determine how
many available seats we have now please
take this moment to turn off your cell
phones and please we ask you not to use
flash photography and for the question
and answer portion please raise your
hand and an usher will bring a
microphone to you William Doherty is
here with us today courtesy of Joe and
Barb gross bow and leopold's ice cream
William J where are they
William Jay Dardenne served eight years
in the US Marine Corps before joining
the Central Intelligence Agency where he
served as an Operations Officer for 17
years
dr. Daugherty is professor emeritus of
government at the University of
California Irvine he is the author of
executive secrets covert action and the
presidency and in the shadow of the
Ayatollah a CIA hostage in heart in Iran
and he also lives here in Savannah
please give a warm hug Tong Tong town
welcome to William dougherty
thank you all for coming what an amazing
that crowd shouldn't you all be out
playing tennis or walking your dogs or
something instead of good I do want to
need to correct one thing I just did a
degree at the University of California
actually I'm an emeritus professor at
Armstrong and since i have a captive
audience here i'm going to digress from
my normal talk for two minutes and
address the University of Georgia Board
of Regents about 10 or 12 years ago
Armstrong was a commuter college with no
residence halls if everybody remembers
and Georgia Southern was 19,000 students
and as I recall the Board of Regents
said well georgia Southern's a little
too large
let's make Armstrong a residential
college and turn it into another
regional school and we'll take some of
the pressure off off Georgia Southern
that happened Armstrong has beautiful
residential halls the school is growing
and and now here is this phenomenally
incredibly stupid decision to somehow
merge these two schools that are an hour
apart if I may tell the Board of Regents
this is not going to be cost-effective
more than that we are the south and
history and southern tradition is
priceless do not merge the schools
or you will burn in hell actually
well that wraps up my talk I appreciate
you all for coming our strong was the
best job I ever had I had a lot of good
jobs not including the the one when I
was 15 or I cleaned up after the ponies
at the amusement park but that that was
good training for the Marine Corps and
and eventually for for going to Iran I
do want to talk about what I saw in Iran
at the age of 31 and what Iraq has
become today and what the Iranians back
then sort of thought they were going to
accomplish and what has since transpired
which was not anything at all like they
had hoped or believed that they were
going to accomplish I am not at all
prejudiced against Islam I am Not Afraid
of Islam I have no problem with Muslims
I have no problem with Iranians I do
have problems with individuals
regardless of their religion or their
ethnic background or their beliefs who
are extremists and who take their
beliefs to extreme measures one of the
absolute very best students I had at
Armstrong was a young lady who is a Shia
Muslim remember Iranians are Shia Muslim
and everybody I gotta recognize pretty
familiar with the Sunni Shia split in
Islam but it doesn't stop there there
are 33 different sects of Shia Islam
shows you how divided that religion is
and that part of the religion and the 33
different sects
run from very pacifistic to the extreme
Iranian interpretation of Islam this
young lady has gone on to do absolutely
wonderful things in
the world of charity and nongovernmental
organizations in third-world countries
she has paid a price for that in one
country where she was in a very terrible
car wreck she was in Kenya when the
riots were there she had to walk around
dead people to get to her job several
years ago when she was married in in
Vancouver Canada I was honored to have
received an invitation to her wedding
and I flew up to Vancouver to be in her
wedding which took place at a beautiful
mosque and I was delighted to do that
and I consider her one of my top-notch
students and a very close friend so I
have no concern at all about the
religion of Islam and those who practice
Islam just with with individuals the
Iranians who took the embassy for the
most part were well-meaning but very
very naive the I would divide the group
into sort of three age brackets those in
their late 20s and early 30s were
college graduates or should have been
college graduates my chief interrogator
an individual that I spent a hundred or
so very delightful hours with sometimes
12 hours at a time through the middle of
the night in less than comfortable
circumstances actually had gone to the
University of California Berkeley for a
few years and I am a product at the
University of California system only
only Irvine where we were so close to
the beach that nobody was radicalized
except when surf was up
but I do understand Berkeley and I
thought it was very appropriate that
this guy gone to Berkeley although
although he was radicalized in the
different direction and they were
responsible I think for what passed for
leadership the whole country was really
in chaos home ad had more or less taken
over and there were a lot of struggles
going on nobody seemed to be in charge
and and that's what the CIA was actually
there there were three of us operations
officers I had only been in the agency
for nine months when I got off the plane
in Tehran and the airport was an arc ear
at large and and I was wondering you
know what in the world had I gotten
myself into
and that feeling never never past in the
53 days I was there before they they
took the embassy the the whole point
that we were there was that the the
Carter Administration and indeed the
Western world had no idea what was going
on in Iran because the Iranians didn't
and things changed
hourly nobody really knew who was in
charge who was who was influencing how
meny that seemed to be the last person
that talked to him even if it was a lady
who who swept the floors and there was a
tremendous need in Washington to find
out what the new policies were going to
be and we were most of the the station
assets had fled as they should have
after the February 14th as you recall
the embassy was also attacked then by by
a group of militants mostly thugs we
call it the the February 14th
Valentine's Day open house they were in
the embassy for about three hours which
affected the the thinking in Washington
in our situation so we were really
trying to find anybody
who had any access to power who can tell
us what was going on and who might be
willing to cooperate with a Great Satan
it was very slim pickings I was assigned
undercover as the embassy political
military affairs officer and was overtly
working with the Ministry of Industry of
Foreign Affairs and the Ministry of
Defence because of the billions and
billions of dollars of military
equipment that had been sold to Iran the
Iranians had paid for it and then in the
middle of the Revolution the Carter
Administration embargoed all of that so
the Iranians wanted their money back or
the equipment they weren't going to get
the equipment and the money was a real
sticking problem and you may recall just
a few months ago they actually got the
money after all these years so that was
one of my jobs and then at night when I
should have been sleeping or doing other
things productive I was out on the
streets doing doing spy stuff rather
unproductively most of the time although
I was making friends with the guy who
worked in the prime minister's office
and things were progressing well and got
permission to as we we call him the spy
business to pitch him to recruit him to
spy for us no way was I going to spy I
was going to get this guy to do it for
me because spine yourself can be
hazardous to your health so I was gonna
you know I had diplomatic immunity you
know so this guy was going to go to jail
not me and and so I pitched and I said
you know we could use your help we don't
know what's going on you know you you
could really help us and he says you
know the Russians made me that same
offer last week
and I didn't know what to say because we
covered a lot of scenarios in my
training but that wasn't one of them
so I just asked him to have another
drink and and we we changed the subject
needless to say that was that was a
pitch that didn't didn't work out well
like all the others but the guys so here
was this this group of older guys who
were the leaders at 20 he's late 20s and
30s then there was a middle group who
were sort of in charge of our day-to-day
once we were captured and and turned
into a we just thought we were sort of
captives for a while we wouldn't do we
didn't know we were hostages until about
the third week when in my case one of my
guards said you you know I said hey you
know what to let us go home he says you
can't go home your hostages and I
thought huh what does that mean I mean I
knew what it meant but I didn't really
know what it meant
for me at the time I knew what you know
I know how to read a dictionary anyone
hostage meant but you know you don't
apply those things to yourself when you
know when some 19 year old kid says
you're my hostage and then there were
the 19 year olds who were our day-to-day
guards and with whom we had most of the
interaction and some of them were
hostile and and some of them were amazed
to find after being with us for weeks or
months at a time that really you know we
were just Americans kind of like they
were just irani ins we weren't supermen
we didn't you know talk to Mars on our
watch we didn't have shoes that that had
you know you can take him off and and
get under the cone of silence and talk
to somebody and that really had a an
impact on their their view of us
everybody I think is pretty much aware
that the Iranians came to the embassy to
break relations with the United States
there were a number of events that
started happening that summer that were
unrelated but the Iranians put them
together to concoct a because their
great conspiracy theorist
they put they put these unrelated events
together to say aha this means the
United States are planning to have
another coup in our country like 1953
and we weren't Jimmy Carter had had told
the regime and that was what the State
Department and the embassy was doing was
telling the regime that we were there to
recognize their their revolution and to
accept their their new government to try
to work with them because we had other
interests besides just the government of
Iran in the north of the country there
were listening posts that were way up in
the mountains that overlooked 300 miles
of Kazakhstan desert to the Soviet
missile test ranges and we were using
the CIA in the United States Air Force
we're losing using these missile or
these listening posts to intercept
telemetry from missile launches from
which number one we could discern an
awful lot of intelligence about the
Soviet missile capabilities and number
two we could download and decode their
telemetry which was a violation of the
strategic arm limitations treaties and
and tell them that first of all they
were violating the treaty that way but
they would also violate the treaties and
other ways and Henry Kissinger would
pick up the phone and call his
counterpart in Moscow and say you have
violated the treaty this way in that way
and you got to stop it and they would so
these were very very important sites in
fact most of the United States interest
in Iran was not with Iran not with the
Iranian government it was first of all
with the Soviets being right there on
the Soviet border there were a lot of
Soviet diplomats and intelligence
officers in Tehran and they were very
very active and there were also Chinese
and Eastern Europeans in Iran that we
were targeted after so that was another
something else that we were very
interested in so
the the Iranians however you know we're
focused on the United States focused on
her support to the Shah angry at the
Shah since 1972 with the Nixon
administration really getting very close
to the United States the Shah was
spending billions of dollars of Iranian
oil on weapons to be a leader of the
world and the Iranian people were very
poor
most of the Iranians didn't have
electricity didn't have running water
didn't have sewers they had poor
education they had poor health care and
they saw the Shah squandering their
their birthright to buy these weapons to
be something that they didn't want to be
what they wanted was to have a better
life very reasonably so and they blamed
the United States for a lot of their
woes in a certain sense rightly so but
also rather misguidedly in a lot of
respects as well so they wanted to come
to the embassy to finally break
relations with the United States forced
the United States completely out of Iran
so they as they thought they could
become their own country I had some very
well-educated very smart ER audience
tell me that they were absolutely
certain that every morning the Shah of
Iran got up and phoned the head of the
Iran desk at the CIA to get his marching
instructions for the day the head of the
Iran descoth the CIA was at gs-14 which
away equates basically to a lieutenant
colonel and I just don't think that Shah
would call a lieutenant colonel
to find out what he should be doing for
the day given the Shahs ego maniacal
personality but they believed it as well
as a lot of other crazy weird sorts of
things so that's the well-known reason
but they also thought that home-a knee
was backtracking on his promise that he
had made multiple times in Paris to
establish an Islamic regime and they
thought we can combine this group
thought we can combine we can combine
two objectives here we can get the
Americans out of Iran and we can force
home a knee to decide whether he's going
to have a secular government or whether
he's going to have an Islamic regime
like he promised and those two factors
led to the takeover to the embassy and
they thought we'll take the embassy this
will be over in two or three days this
will all be resolved in we're pretty
sure that the Shah then is going or the
the ho mania will decide for the Islamic
regime and here was their dream Iran
will fully be an independent it will not
be under the heel of the United States
or the Western powers so they didn't
mind France and Germany so much although
Germany had a lot to do with the
deprivation zuv saw back in the late
1950s early 60s the United States saw
Slovak going in a direction that we
didn't like in terms of their treatment
of prisoners there the fact that saw vac
was not targeted against threats to the
regime external threats but was targeted
against perceived threats to the Shah
and and became an exceptionally vicious
organization against its own citizens so
Germany and Israel became the principal
trainers of Slavic not the United States
although we we took the blame for it
again because of 1953 which the Iranians
think was absolutely the the thing that
has caused all of their problems ever in
their 3,000 year history
and it's an incredible all the things
that they blamed us for going back to
times when the United States not only
didn't exist but which in which of North
America had not even been discovered but
nonetheless the United States was still
responsible for those problems as well
so they saw you know number one
independence number two they were going
to prosper from this everybody was going
to not necessarily become wealthy but
was going to become what we might
describe as middle class everybody was
going to have health care education was
going to bloom the economy was going to
to take off there was going to be
democracy although they would they would
sort of caveat it and say well you know
yeah we could have we would have freedom
of speech but the government would be
able to say we don't like that speech
and then you wouldn't be able to say
those things but otherwise we'll have
freedom of speech freedom of the press
anybody can write anything they want but
you know if the government doesn't like
it you know you might be told you can't
write that anymore and you know you
might have to go to jail but other than
that we're gonna have freedom of speech
so they had kind of a warped idea of
what what democracy and freedom actually
entailed but they had a lot of bright
ideas and and dreams when I got there
there were about twenty million Iranians
six million living in Tehran of those
six million about five and a half
million lived in abject poverty the half
million that were wealthy were
fabulously wealthy corruption was just
incredible the United States was pouring
billions of dollars into that country
and it wasn't going to the people that
was being siphoned off and in northern
Tehran there were fabulous mansions all
of the the French couturiers were there
the French jewelers it was a wealthy
persons Rodeo Avenue or Rodeo Avenue out
in Los Angeles if if you've had the
amazing opportunity to walk down that
Street and lick the windows a little bit
let shale a vtrene as the French say and
but although it's gonna be sweetness and
light once the the Americans got out
today Iran is 80 million and growing
perhaps 85 million now Tehran itself is
about 20 million of which probably 19
and a half million live in abject
poverty
there has been no trickle-down not there
has been here in the United States
either but that's another point people
are still dirt poor over there there's
still a terrible education system if
they had the ability to go to college
they can turn out a literate replica of
a middle class the college students that
were our captors a lot of them were
second first-year college students some
radical students but but we found their
knowledge of history social sciences
that sort of thing the liberal arts was
roughly about that of a
well-educated eighth or ninth grader
here in American Public Schools woefully
below what we would consider to be an
educated college student the the
population today probably 75 to 80
percent of that population was born
after the Revolution they know that the
promises that a home aney made to
justify the revolution have never come
about again that's the United States
fault and here's a news flash you
probably don't know this but the United
States secretly collaborated with his
son
Saddam Hussein to order Saddam Hussein
to attack Iran in 1980 and I know that
will come as a great surprise to
everybody it probably would come as a
great surprise this is Saddam Hussein if
he happened to be around today but
that's the sort of thing that you know
we are still a convenient scapegoat for
them they are unable to look internally
and and to accept their own mistakes
they are unable to look internally and
to accept their own fate now part of
this is their history they had 3,000
years of being controlled predominantly
by outsiders or controlled by
authoritarian leaders of one sort or
another and and this has given them a
character characteristic that combined
with their version of Shia Islam an
interesting perspective on their lives
it's given them the the belief that they
have no control over anything that they
do it's always conspiracies by outsiders
and nothing is ever their fault I know
many times
when we were their captives we were
blamed for their taking the embassy in
which case I said yeah I will get down
on my knees and objectless for my
miscreant deeds and in return for that
if you'll just take me to the airport
and put me on the you know the next
plane to anywhere I I will I will
apologize to you all the way to the
airport they they weren't that accepting
however in 90 or in 2009 you may recall
there was the Green Revolution ahmadi
Nejad was reelected and it was really
kind of the first time in a number of
years since 1979 that the election for
the presidency in Iran was not really a
free election Iran has an interesting
system these days the there's a Supreme
Council that responds to the the
leadership hominid and they might have a
couple hundred folks or eight hundred
folks who apply to run for the
presidency or for a seat in the
parliament and and then they will go
through and all those that are
unequivocally opposed the regime or or
or in some way not necessarily purely
loyal or eliminated and the half dozen
or so that remained then can actually
run for the presidency but of those that
remain then elections are pretty much
free while a modern Assad's re-election
was not because two of the other
contenders stood to to possibly win and
so the election was rigged and then the
Iranians took to the streets they were
pretty violently repressed illusionary
guards were behind the repression but
the face of the repression were what
were known as the besieged these
teenagers
that made a name for themselves in the
iran-iraq war as 12 and 14 year olds by
running across minefields the ultimate
minesweepers so that when the minefields
were cleared than the the Iranian
soldiers could run across the minefields
with no fear of being blown up I guess
their technology was not sufficiently
advanced to provide them with actual
minesweeping gear that accounted for
thousands and thousands of casualties
during that war it was just awful
so that revolution did not succeed but
it's scared the ruling group very deeply
this was not really understood for quite
a while and it's never really been
covered by the press it's it's in
academic journals sorts of thing but
it's it's never really received the
coverage that it should have because
that was one of the instrumental things
that led up to the the nuclear agreement
that was signed last year the ruling
class stands to lose a lot all the
mullahs that are that are high level
that are involved in the government from
homini on down are filthy rich they all
have multi-million and billion dollar
accounts in Switzerland and elsewhere
the Revolutionary Guard which is a
separate military service from those
normal military units in the Ministry of
Defence the Revolutionary Guard has its
own Army Navy Air Force and special
operations unit and they get preference
over the regular military in the
Ministry of Defence they are considered
to be much more religiously reliable
they are so much so that the regular
Iranian Navy has been kicked out of the
Persian Gulf and all of the things that
are taking place with the Iranian
vessels in the Persian Gulf are the
Revolutionary Guards not the Iranian
Navy the Revolutionary Guards naval
forces not the Iranian Navy
the Revolutionary Guards controls about
60% of the economy in Iran they run the
oil business they control and own the
oil business the National Guard ass
enterprises they own the the Iranian
telecommunications industry they own the
Iranian automobile industry yes they
make an automobile that makes the Nash
grambler look like a miniature Rolls
Royce they they they handle all the
smuggling that goes into Iran which was
required of because of the sanctions
that were in they are the the leaders of
the Iranian or the the Revolutionary
Guards are a very wealthy group and
should there be any kind of a revolution
that would even partly succeed or
disrupt the society these people would
not only lose their wealth but they
might actually end up losing their lives
as well as what happened in 1979 with
the revolution after ho Meany came back
so that was one impetus and the idea
that and the election itself sort of got
them thinking we need to you know the
sanctions were kind of kind of a
sideline we need to pacify the people
because again about 75 percent of the
people were disillusioned and they know
what the rest of the world has even and
even back in the early 1980s just in
Tehran alone there were over a half a
million satellite dishes illegal the Sun
would go down satellite dishes would go
up all over the city they would see BBC
they would see German TV they would see
the French channels they would see
American channels one of their favorite
shows honest to god was sorry one of
their favourite
one of their favorite shows was Baywatch
I'm serious you cannot make this stuff
up
and so so they know what they've know
what they've been missing what the
Western world has what the opportunities
are out there and so the the leadership
the Islamic Relief came to realize that
they need to do something to take the
edge off the people to to give them some
sense of the semblance of hope to maybe
actually make their lives a little
better so that they can keep their their
places now there's a lot more to it the
Iranian leadership is a nebulous concept
it's very fragmented there are there are
little points of power all over the
country and ghom and Tehran Mashhad
Tabriz you have struggles between the
Ministry of Defense in the Revolutionary
Guard you have struggles between the the
council's the religious councils that
advise Khamenei and the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs the the Ministry of
Finance the banks need to have policies
that enable them to interact with
Western banks but yet the the Muslims
need or want them to follow Islamic
interpretations of banking rules and so
it's a very complex society at this
point it's very difficult to understand
I certainly don't pretend to understand
it it's and it's hard at times to get
information accurate information out of
there it is competing circles of power
centers and you never know who's in
charge and with the Revolutionary Guards
and what they're doing for example in
the Persian Gulf you you don't know
whether they're being directed by homini
or or whether they're acting
on their own which they have been known
to do they'll act on their own they'll
cause a problem like when they they
captured the British sailors and then
and then the political side has a
problem that they didn't ask for that
that they have to solve without losing
face the real danger with the
Revolutionary Guards is they're going to
get froggy one day and do something that
is going to trigger a response that they
hadn't anticipated and all of a sudden
there's going to be a real problem so
it's a very difficult society to to
figure let me take my last couple of
minutes and then I'll take questions the
nuclear thing I know this is very
unpopular probably in this area of the
country or a lot of the country I'm for
it and I always was for it I'll tell you
why and I have read every word of that
agreement it's online you can read it
for yourself it's not easy to understand
I don't pretend to understand the
science part of it if I if I was good in
math and science I'd be a real doctor
instead of the fake kind and but there's
a lot in it's very complicated the parts
that are you know readily understandable
or sort of understandable you can see
that it wasn't easy to reach that
agreement it took a long time it took a
lot a lot of man-hours seven countries
have agreed to at six the the six powers
and Iran the Iranian so far have
followed it why again because lifting
the sanctions is very important to the
leadership if it wasn't they wouldn't
have entered into the agreement in the
first place they did not enter into the
agreement to disown it a year after they
entered into it
the and in terms of the the ballistic
missiles that's a different thing
a year ago
there was an agreement or the UN
resolution that said the Iranians shall
not shall not test missiles that will be
capable of carrying a nuclear warhead
that agreement was changed a lot when
this nuclear agreement came out that
said we hope the Iranians will not test
missiles so they're testing the missiles
it's not forbidden
it's just hoped that they won't do it
and of course of course they are and
they may may very well be looking
anticipating someday to put a nuclear
warhead on but you know so far the
nuclear agreement itself is is holding
up it guarantees that there will be no
nuclear weapon for ten years without it
there's no guarantee that there won't be
a nuclear weapon in two years ten years
is a long time tell me who in 1981 what
have foreseen that the Soviet Union
would have completely disappeared in
1991 who in 1981 would have thought that
in 1991 we would have completely beaten
Saddam Hussein in a war and who ten
years later we would be back fighting
again and ten years after that we would
still have five years to go in a war
that's still going on who in in 1939
thought that we would be fighting a
major world war on two continents on two
fronts and be the world's leader ten
years later in in 1949 ten years is a
long time in international affairs who
knows what's going to happen in ten
years in Iran or nine years now there
could be a complete change of government
there could be a revolution that would
or a peaceful change of government that
would change everything
who knows the the the possibilities are
endless and probably what could happen
in nine years would be something that
nobody could foresee anyway so it's
worth ten years to keep them from
building a nuclear weapon
maybe on 10 years and one day they will
produce a nuclear stockpile maybe in 10
years in one day they could be our close
allies or something in between so 10
years is a long time the Germans the
French are allies the British they are
very happy with the Paulo with the the
agreement and it is monitored strictly
and with close scrutiny by the
International Atomic Energy Agency and
the IAEA is on the ground in Iran and it
is visiting the the nuclear sites not
necessarily perhaps like they would
lower they would want to but more than
they had been and they were surprised by
the accesses they've been getting even
the Israelis under the table are very
happy with the way it's going the
Israeli intelligence services the
Israeli Foreign Ministry or for the
agreement in the first place it was the
politicians that for their own political
purposes were very much against it the
last three leaders of Mossad arguably
one of the best intelligence services in
the world and probably have better
sources into the Iranian nuclear program
than we do we're very much for the
agreement so for these reasons now I
could be wrong
you know next week Tehran could could in
the desert blow up a 20-megaton weapon
and and then you can get the pitchforks
and torches and march on my house I
won't be there but you could do it but
right now I think it's worth supporting
and not that I'm gonna you know trying
to convince anybody who believes
otherwise I'm just stating my opinion
but but this is how I look at things
okay let me go ahead and and take any
questions
nobody's got any questions for Oliver
you know Here I am the the one thing the
book festivals done is it's got me into
church and it's got me wearing a tie and
I'm you know how did this happen okay
sir you had your hand up first
[Music]
the question was what is since I have a
modest background in intelligence and in
the military what is my assessment of
the rescue attempt in 1980 had Colonel
Beckwith and Delta Force been able to
reach the embassy I was very interested
in that when I came back I was an
enlisted marine for a while and then and
then headquarters Marine Corps really
screwed up and sent me to OCS and I went
through flight school actually this is
why I came here to to Savannah
let's see everybody probably knows used
to be a Naval Air Station and I was
there as an enlisted guy for air traffic
control school and then I went to
advanced flight training down there and
then had a tour in Vietnam on an
aircraft carrier when my f4 squadron was
we were screwed out of a med crews and
sent to Vietnam instead I didn't know
they were that desperate I was able to
talk to some people after I got back
including a three-star general who at
the Pentagon was just up to his eyeballs
in the planning and everything for the
mission he said he worked eight hours a
day on his regular job and they need
eight hours a day on the planning a
couple of things about the mission first
of all Charlie Beckwith told the
president that he expected about 25% of
the hostages to be killed in the rescue
attempt as well as probably some Delta
Force guys rescue guys and maybe a few
wounded as well who could not be
retrieved the CIA assessment was about
30% of the hostages would be killed and
there would be wounded who could not be
retrieved so the first thing is here's
here's a rescue attempt it is going to
get a significant portion of the rescue
e's dead as well as perhaps leave
hostages behind so I will leave it to
you them all over how wise it was to do
a
to attempt when actually things were
going very good for us our lives had
gotten better after about four months of
some very mm well for some of us you
know not real happy times and so I Vance
had just come back from Europe where he
had finally talked the Europeans into
instigating embargoes economic embargoes
and so forth against Iran and the
Iranians had always said are not the
Iranians the Europeans had always held
off doing it and finally they said okay
we will institute embargoes if you do if
you promise not to do a military any
military action against Iran so in April
the end of April your middle of April
science comes back from Europe and he
says mr. president I've got great news
the Europeans have bought into finally
after five months have bought into
embargoes against Iran and and and I of
course promised them that we're not
going to have any military action
against Iran and so the world it's
wonderful and President Carter says sigh
I've got to tell you something we're
gonna have a military operation in five
days so sighs says mr. president here's
my resignation and they went ahead and
had the military operation now this
Lieutenant General that I used to talk
with we used to have lunch about once a
month together
he I asked him exactly that question
what were the odds and he said if you
talk to the individual commanders the
Ranger commander Charlie Beckwith of
Delta Force the the Marine pilots that
flew the helicopters the c-130 pilots
anybody involved with it each of them
would say we can do our job we we are
fully confident that we can succeed in
our job talking to this lieutenant
general who was in daily contact with
every with all five members of the Joint
Chiefs and with a general vault Major
General Vaught who was the overall
mission commander
he said nobody had any confidence that
it was going to succeed it was so
complex so complicated that every
minuscule part had
fall just right into place at each
perfect time and he said nobody at that
level really had much confidence in it I
don't know whether they communicated
that to the president
I know the president was under a great
deal of stress to do something he had
just lost the New York primary to Teddy
Kennedy he was up for re-election so
that's that's that yes sir
anybody got a microphone handy somebody
got one in your pocket thank you with
the length of the hostage crisis I
assume that some of the hostages would
have had medical events how was the
medical treatment or lack thereof hmm
not well I know when I had a really bad
cold I had to steal toilet paper from
the head and then they chastise me for
stealing toilet paper and I said well
give me some Kleenex since we don't have
any Kleenex and I said well I gotta use
I got to use toilet paper these they
said well you can't use toilet paper
because it's not meant for tough though
I don't I'm sure it was was very
difficult on the guys who were in their
60s late 60s
Richard Queen did end up with multiple
sclerosis now that I understand is not
necessarily a hard disease to to
diagnose once the symptoms really are
manifested but the Iranians couldn't do
it they did bring in doctors they took
rich to a hospital he was confined in
the hospital for awhile and they still
couldn't diagnose
his MS and so they put him on an
airplane to Switzerland in the summer
because they were absolutely convinced
he was going to die
most of the hostages that had some type
of an ailment the flu or cold or cut or
something
we had a medical corpsman an army
corpsman or they call us medic is what
they call min the army and he was
allowed to treat the hostages my
colleagues and if they needed a pill or
something like that and then he could
tell the Iranians what to bring if it
wasn't too expensive if it was myself
for the chief of station or a couple of
the senior military officers I guess we
just would have died because we weren't
we weren't given any any treatment sir
and then and then I'll get you it next
ed to questions who planted the
landmines that you talked about and how
former will do you think the
Revolutionary Guard is in world military
circles the landmines were planted to by
the Iraqis during their war they planted
millions and millions the Revolutionary
Guard today numbers about 125,000 I
don't put much stock in their Air Force
although they're flying
Micke fighters but their David
McPheeters are the ones that the Iraqis
you know flew to Iran in 1991 thinking
that you know they would have a country
left over and and I guess they did after
Desert Storm but the Iranians said thank
you very much you're not giving them
back and the Soviet Union has gone down
and they've helped refurbish them a
little bit and whatever but there's
they're not frontline fighters by any
means they do not have any large ships
but then the Iranian Navy doesn't have
any large ships there's two or three
that are sitting on the the bottom of
the Persian Gulf now from 1987 the the
real problem the the RG is the Kurds
force they're special operations they're
the ones that went into Iraq taught the
Iraqis how to use those shaped charges
and landmines that have killed so many
Americans they're the ones that are
working with Hezbollah against the
Israelis they're the ones that would
help the Hizballah's factions down in
Argentina that blew up the two Jewish
sites in Buenos Aires if there is a war
with with Iran it is the rev guards that
will support the hood smallest cells in
various areas of the world that then
will be more than likely turned loose on
American targets worldwide so the Kurds
force is a genuine threat but they're
still not terribly competent they keep
losing commanders in Syria it seems like
you know they have a commander named and
they'll go to Syria and the next thing
you know they'll be dead they've gone
through like five five commanders in the
last year and a half I'm not sure who's
killing him besides us but I'm you know
if I was an officer in the codes force
and they asked me to say how would you
like to be the commander you know I'd
probably have to go clean out my sock
drawer something I don't think I'd want
to want to do that
so what
so with these five partners what would
be the impact of us withdrawing if they
don't we will be isolated from that sort
of thing
first of all other countries are going
to be reluctant to engage in any
agreements like this that would have
such a gravity attached to it it will
certainly damage our standing with our
partners maybe not so much Russia but
certainly the French the Germans the
British are very closest allies well we
will cause a serious problem with them
down the road in terms of future joint
projects and agreements we we will look
kind of foolish to the rest of the world
which Mayer name may not be bad but
again there are unintended and
unforeseen consequences that would
derive from this none of which I think
would would be good I mean as long as
the Iranians are seen to be fulfilling
their into the the agreement and as long
as they are certified as following
agreement by the IAEA and by the by our
partners a withdrawal from that
agreement unilaterally without just
cause will only work to the detriment of
the United States in the short term and
probably in the long term if we withdraw
even if the other five countries want to
adhere to it that would be reason enough
for the Iranians to withdraw and and at
that point there is no longer any there
were no longer be any restrictions on
their their ability to develop a nuclear
weapon and that would be the worst part
yes forever yes ma'am
an interesting scenario just a couple of
days before the Revolution a chauffeur
was
I mean the Amorian ambassador to the
airport there were an ambassador to
France to the airport
the it was very early in the morning and
the fog was very very heavy as he
manipulated his way through the streets
he hid a robed gentleman the robed
gentleman turned out to be Ayatollah
Khomeini imagine what the world would
have been like if he knocked him off
rather than knocking him down yeah from
your lips to God's ears oh I'll tell you
another another imagine this South from
the from the time the Shah left Iran
South Africa was was begging the Shah to
come and go into exile in South Africa
South Africa has wonderful medical
facilities they promised the Shah
security the serenity everything and the
shot in do it Shawn never did and the
reason was after the the the British
kicked the Shah out of Iran and exiled
him to Mauritius his next stop was South
Africa and there the raises Shah died
and Shah pallavi just did not want to
die in the same country that his father
did and that's why he never did go to
South Africa for sanctuary and if he did
imagine what the world would be like
today one of the things that the
speaking of what else one of the things
that students never first saw was a rise
of Hezbollah the Iranians today have
killed almost a thousand Americans in
acts of terrorism they were responsible
for the destruction of the embassy in
Beirut in 1983 with 17 dead Americans
they were responsible for the
destruction of the Marine barracks in
Beirut in April of I'm sorry October of
1983 241 dead America dead American
marines not many wounded because that at
that time was the largest non-nuclear
explosion ever in history 241 dead
Marines and there was no retaliation on
the part of the Americans
since then the Copart hours 19 dead
americans by grace of god there was not
more multiple e over 900 americans have
been killed by iranian terrorism and you
know what there has not been a single
day of payment on the part of the
Iranians we have never made the Iranians
pay in any significant way for killing
Americans are we done okay sorry
[Applause]
thank you dr. Guardi gosh we could stay
up forever but upon exiting the venue
today our wonderful volunteers will
enthusiastically accept your donation to
the Savannah Book Festival it is because
of your generosity we're able to keep
the festival free on Saturdays thank you
[Music]
[Music]